[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
liebet eure feinde zu jesus gesagt haben
und das scheint ganz aus habe der
kapitalismus sich dieses gebot zu herzen
genommen denn einer der bekanntesten
kritiker des kapitalismus ist längst zum
konsumgut geworden nicht nur seine
bücher und filme verkaufen sich bestens
nein von meinem heutigen gast gibt es
sogar aufkleber caps und auch super
lätzchen für kinder herzlich willkommen
hlawatschek vielen dank ich meine ehre
gleichfalls es ist mir eine ehre hier
aus aber letztlich für kinder
caps aufkleber der kapitalismus ist
schon ziemlich schlau oder das macht den
größten kritiker am besten zu verkaufen
ein motto wie ich schäme mich nicht
dafür weil ich weiß worum es hier geht
es mag vielleicht ein bisschen arrogant
und auch ein wenig bitter klingen aber
auf diese weise versuchen meine gegner
mich zu diskreditieren
sie sagen geht hin und hört ihm zu es
ist unterhaltsam aber nimmt sie nicht
ernst
ich glaube man kann beides tun man kann
amüsant und gleichzeitig ernst sein wenn
ich noch kurz etwas anfügen darf weil
ich es sonst vergesse ich sage ihnen
auch warum ich habe eine sehr tragische
theorie dazu
ist ihnen aufgefallen dass die besten
filme über den holocaust komödien sind
lavita bella und andere nun wenn der
terror ein gewisses maß erreicht hat
kann man ihn nicht mehr als tragödie
abhandelt
[Musik]
ich gebe ihnen ein beispiel
entschuldigen sie den schlechten
geschmack
ich sie foltere können sie wie ein held
handeln und mehr ihre entblößte brust
entgegenhalten egal was sie tun ich
werde nicht aber in auschwitz oder im
gulag verliert man diese würde man kann
nur durch dummen humor überleben ich
werde jetzt kein beispiel an fügen aber
es gibt eine unterart von witzen über
auschwitz oder in bosnien über
srebrenica die absolut geschmacklos sind
ich kann also damit leben
dass der humor der da drin steckt ist
eigentlich die einzige waffe um mit
ihrer theorie mit der mit der tiefe auch
umzugehen mit dem was sie uns sagen ich
habe noch because i'm not aber nicht
weil ich besonders tiefgründig lehrer
gut laufe schon einen gewissen tiefgang
zu haben sondern weil ich nicht der
typische max ist bin ich habe eine
pessimistische botschaft die
werden wir heute ein bisschen anschauen
sie sind einer der bekanntesten aber
auch umstrittensten
intellektuellen unserer zeit sie wurden
als gefährlichster philosoph des westens
bezeichnet manchmal auch als elvis der
kulturtheorie und so weit dass ich
schreibe ich will das hasse ich weiß
dass sie das hassen ich hab's trotzdem
gesagt sie schreiben über popkultur über
politik über toiletten und sechs genauso
wie über marx und hegel und das wie ich
finde immer auf eine überraschende art
zu schaden sagen immer die dinge sind
genau was wir meinen und das ist das
interessante und heute wollen wir in
dieser stunde man so ein bisschen die
theorie von slawa cicek und die denker
die dahinter stehen besser verstehen
darf ich hier anknüpfen michael lang
weil diese rhetorische figur um meine
person bettink dort auf dich rhetorische
figur auf mein die dinge sind aber
ist es nicht so dass wir gerade heute
oft regelrechte sprachliche verrenkungen
beobachten etwa in bezug auf die ukraine
manche die eigentlich gegen die
russische aggression sein sollten
verneinen in gewisser weise die
offensichtliche tatsache dass russland
ein kleineres und angegriffen
meist wird gesagt und es ist nicht so
einfach die dinge sind komplizierter
manchmal lässt uns gerade die anspielung
auf tiefe und komplexität die
offensichtlichen tatsachen vergessen die
ob wir ja das stimmt das stimmt über die
ukraine müssen wir noch reden bevor wir
aber über die theorie dahinter reden
hinter ihrer kultur analysen und zeit
analysen die viele kennen
müssen wir glaube ich persönlich
anfangen sie sind 73 geworden leider ja
wie geht es ihnen gesundheitlich
ich habe ein schweres diabetes und so
weiter eine gehört probleme sorry but to
make up für loser zunge aber um einen
philosophischen des zu machen manchmal
vergesse ich dass ich kein deutsch
sprechen
was ich jetzt sage wird die leute wieder
schockieren und dafür in trier gehe ich
nicht aber ich meine es ernst
meine lösung all diese schwierigkeiten
und das betrifft die senilität überleben
ist und ich entschuldige mich arbeit
macht frei der standing mile ist arbeit
macht frei
die nazis haben diese idee brutal
zweckentfremdet ich der gedanke ist ja
nicht narzisstisch das war ein
schlechter witz
natürlich macht arbeit in auschwitz
nicht frei aber was einen in diesen
verrückten zeiten überleben lässt ich
habe gesundheitliche probleme mache mir
sorgen über den zustand der welt ist ein
grund ritual ein arbeitspensum und dass
man sich strikt hält
als ich kürzlich ein chor wieder krank
healey glücklicherweise nicht ernsthaft
aber unangenehm ging die arbeit einfach
weiter
aber es muss eine ich kann nicht sagen
kreative das wäre zu arrogant sinnvolle
und erfüllende art sein ohne das könnte
ich nicht überleben sagt rektor
das heißt sie nicht ruhiger geworden sie
machen immer noch viele sie schreiben
eine fast 900 bücher geschrieben muss
man sagen sie schreiben weitermachen
vorträge es sind verschiedene versionen
desselben materials ich nenne es
ironisch ökologisches schreiben ich
rezitieren
fenster würde ich von meiner pfadfinder
mentalität sprechen wenn ich nicht jeden
tag lese und schreibe fühle ich mich
schuldig ich verlor meine
daseinsberechtigung
nichts macht nicht glücklicher als das
richtige wort zu finden
als philosoph wissen sie dass man oft
einer idee nachhängt die irgendwo in der
luft schwebt weil einem der richtige
begriff fehlt
und plötzlich ist er da und das obszöner
könnte ich sagen das ist schon fast ein
geistiger orgasmus let's go league light
lait ob sie mental organ das ist das
ziel aber trotzdem noch mal auf das
alter zurückzukommen sie haben gesagt
die arbeit ist ist zentral für sie gibt
den hautstruktur sind was ist mit dem
tod denken sie häufiger antut wenn sie
älter werden also seine
zink jod ich denke nicht auf eine
mystische oder orientalische weise an
den tod in
frankreich bemüht man gern mit della
pace um mit binsenwahrheiten etwas
weisheit einfließen zu lassen
etwa in der art eine halbe minute vor
seinem tod war michael de la police noch
am leben
das ist meine unbezähmbare haltung ich
glaube fest daran und das ist nicht
bildlich gemeint das leben als
lebendiger toter zu leben in leaving in
your life the living dead living dead in
der essenz für mich infizierter
schreiben den eigenen tod bereits
akzeptiert zu haben der philosoph
jacques derrida mit dem ich nicht im
besten einvernehmen stand formulierte
gewarnt dass dem schreiben eine
testamentarische funktion zukommt als ob
man dabei seinen eigenen tod
vorwegnehmen
auseinandersetzung mit dem eigenen tod
und ist eigentlich
es geht nicht darum vom tod besessen zu
sein sondern ihn als ein lästiges und
notwendiges details akzeptieren aber
sonst nicht weiter zu beachten und
weiterzuarbeiten bis man zusammenbricht
von working die lucanet die rede nach
darum über den tod jetzt am anfang weil
in den letzten zwei jahren sind zwei
sachen passiert nämlich die pandemie und
jetzt der krieg in der ukraine und beide
haben uns auch mit dem tod und mit elend
konfrontiert und sie haben über beides
natürlich nachgedacht haben über die
pandemie auch zwei bücher geschrieben
das ist das zweite davon vielleicht am
anfang zur pandemie
was hat dieses kleine unsichtbare virus
für philosophische einsichten angestoßen
bei ihnen
als philosoph habe ich sofort diese
parallele zwischen hegel und dem virus
gezogen aus hebels feder stammt ja
dieses unendlich spekulative urteil der
geist ist ein knochen dass gegensätze
auf
der
identischen
opposition friederike der große deutsche
ja es ist sehr wichtig ist
vielleicht gelingt
madia wo sieht man denn ein
meine idee war die folgende ich habe
festgestellt dass viele der heutigen
aber auch früheren philosophen und
denker wie etwa der
kognitionswissenschaftler daniel dennett
oder auch richard dawkins
dich ich schätze ihn sehr als koalitions
wissenschaftler hat er die idee mit
geprägt dass der menschliche geist ein
virus träger zu sein scheint wir werden
kontrolliert von unserer gedanken bei
viren sind
gebiet ich freue mich immer wenn ich auf
unerwartet der verbindungen stoße wissen
sie wer diesen gedanken als erstes
entwickelt hat
er wird normalerweise als konservativ
und langweilig ab gedankenfetzen aber
mehr als durch leo tolstoi er schuf eine
ganze theorie um den gedanken dass unser
geist zwar nicht von viren aber von
bazillen gesteuert wird die sich
vermehren
ich sage dass unser geist in einem
gewissen sinne von viren bevölkert ist
von unseren gedanken dem entfremdeten
symbolischen system das sich durch uns
reproduziert
aber was heißt das was heißt das dass
das findet sich auch bei richard dawkins
auch wenn ich mit seiner formulierung
nicht einverstanden bin
er entwickelte die idee der nemo als
viren des geistes
das sind wir ideen die wir gerne
weitergehen und 20 verbreiten
gemäß dieser vorstellung sind aber der
nehmer die ideen der tatsächlich aktive
teil und wir das bloße trägermedium für
deren replikation
noch spekulativer könnte man sagen dass
der kapitalismus selbst ein virus ist
[Musik]
ja es handelt sich um ein virtuelles
anonymous system das aber unsere
existenz bestimmt mit hegel müsste man
formulieren nicht der geist ist ein
knochen sondern der geist ist ein virus
dieses pandemische virus hat uns also
damit konfrontiert dass es keine
ausnahme darstellt wir leben in einem
universum der wir
fahren darf ich habe nur eine stunde das
ist ja
jeder
genossen und
ich weiß
was ich ernsthaft sagen möchte sie haben
das gut eingeführt es ist ja nicht nur
die pandemie und jetzt der krieg wir
sind heute in der ära der vier reiter
der apokalypse
es begann mit dem ersten reiter der die
solche brachte das virus
der zweite reiter steht für den krieg
den er jetzt
vielleicht droht gar ein neuer weltkrieg
dann der hunger
wir alle wissen jetzt um die bedeutung
der ukraine und russlands für die
versorgung der welt mit weizen
vor dem hintergrund der globalen
erwärmung brot eine ernsthafte
hungerkrise
der vierte reiter steht für den atom
ich würde hier eine moderne wendung
machen ich meine also nicht den tod also
normalen teil des lebens
wenn man mir fragen zum tod stellt
zitiere ich gerne mein lieblings kaffee
tee aus der zeit der solidarnosc
bewegung in polen für mich die beste
definition des lebens
leben ist eine krankheit die sexuell
übertragen wird und mit dem tod endet
mein punkt ist darüber habe ich ein buch
geschrieben hegel im verdrahteten gehirn
das ist nicht nur um das physisch
biologische oder liebe geht
wichtiger noch sind die folgen der
totalen vernetzung unseres gehirns
ein notebook ich meine damit nicht nur
diese kapitalistische die totale
kontrolle die all unsere bewegungen
aufzeichnen wir stehen an der schwelle
zur etwas unbekanntem dessen bedeutung
wir nicht kennen
auf einem sehr rudimentären niveau kann
unser gehirn bereits heute direkt mit
einem computer verbunden und unsere
gedanken aufgezeichnet werden
diese möglichkeit wird uns in den medien
als gute nachricht präsentiert etwa wenn
sie behinderten menschen erlaubt über
ihre gedanken dinge in bewegung zu
setzen
aber es funktioniert eben umgekehrt wenn
wir über unsere gedanken dinge bewegen
können kann das digitale universum auch
direkt in unseren geist ein
wird dadurch nicht unsere tiefste innere
freiheit bedroht die mir auch bleibt
wenn ich fast klafft in ketten liege
auf die selbst die als mein folter kein
zugriff haben das gilt dann nicht mehr
das soll geschehen die distanz zwischen
innen und außen begründet unsere
wahrnehmung der freiheit die man
wenigstens die gedankenfreiheit
erhältlich
freedom eigentlich ingo teimann menschen
und diese freiheit städtischen spiel mit
dieser innovation dass ich sagen die
gedanken ja direkt das ist diese
schnittstelle zwischen
ist das nicht in einem gewissen sinn der
tod von dem was wir bisher unter den
menschen verstanden haben
nach la kommt nicht der physische tod
sondern der zweite trug der ende des
menschen wie wir ihn kannten
wir müssen uns gewahr werden dass wir
uns in einem perfekten sturm befinden
und gleichzeitig von drei oder vier
krisen bedroht sind
ich bin eigentlich kein pessimist aber
ich glaube und als philosoph werden sie
mir beipflichten dass das denken
wichtiger ist denn je
als linker drehe ich mag's elfte these
gerne um die philosophen haben die welt
nur verschieden interpretiert
es kommt aber darauf an sie zu verändern
vielleicht wollten wir im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert die welt zu schnell und zu
radikal verändern heute gilt es sie
vertiefter zu interbrand
genau wie need to do in die private
internet eine sehr philosophische gs
dieser innezuhalten stopp zu machen und
einfach mal nachzudenken richtig und
diesen satz umzukehren und sagen sie
auch wenn wir den kapitalismus
überwinden folgen sie sind ja ein unter
führenden kapitalismuskritiker dann
müssen wir ganz anderes anfangen
nachzudenken über uns selbst über die
gesellschaft über die werten das wollen
wir jetzt heute mal ein bisschen
anschauen wie ihr nachdenken auch sie
uns sind drei figuren sozusagen die
heilige trinität ihres denkens das ist
die dritte hegel marx und lacko
vielleicht würden wir sagen es gibt
marx ich unterbreche sie nur kurz aber
wir sehen heute die grenzen von marx
zum beispiel seine teleologische
vorstellung einer proletarischen
identität die ein letztes ziel anstrebt
und in seinem denken integriert ist
ich bleib im
durchschnitt liegt die revolution der
arbeiterklasse und das proletarische
selbstbewusstsein hätte uns fern jeder
ideologie in eine einzigartige lage
versetzt die handelnden wüssten was zu
tun ist die geschichte lege offen
ich denke wir sollten hier von marx zu
hegel zurückkehren es mag verrückt
klingen aber für mich ist hegel der
philosoph der unseren geist für die
offene zukunft schärft und uns hilft die
lehren aus dem zwanzigsten jahrhundert
zu ziehen
in seiner vorrede zu den grundlinien der
philosophie das recht sagt er
die philosophie könne keine aussagen zur
zukunft machen sondern nur etwas
erkennen und auf dem begriff bringen
wenn es mit diesem etwas allmählich zu
ende geht
die eule der minerva
spiegel die sich im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert wie ein fisch im wasser
gefüllt zuerst platzte der erste
weltkrieg als mega katastrophe in den
allgemeinen optimismus der zumindest in
europa angesichts des ständigen
fortschritt in der zweiten hälfte des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts herrschte
dann der stalin ismus der als eine art
befreiung versprechen begann wie ganz
anders endet
dann der fukuyama moment wo wir uns am
ende der geschichte wenden
kegel ist stets auf alles gefasst er
hängt keinen billigen optimismus an egal
wie gut der plan erscheinen mag das ist
das wahre licht der vernunft licht der
vernunft kann ingo friesen sei die
gefahr dass die dinge irgendwie schief
laufen werden was hegel versöhnung nennt
ist letztlich die aussöhnung mit einem
notwendigerweise tragischen resultat
jerry lee
aber das ist wieder typisch
täglich mit mit verlaub das also eine
kreative
wissen sie was das problem ist mit den
heutigen hegel jahnern ich nenne sie
liberale nord nicht dagegen jahren regel
jahner sie sind liberal in dem sinn dass
sie den höchsten wert in der
gegenseitigen anerkennung sehen dann
projizieren sie eine gewisse zukunft
orientierung im hegel hinein gemäss der
regel eine bestimmte sich der zukunft
zeichnet in der volle freiheit und
gegenseitiger anerkennung hast
kam aber zu früh und so suchen sie den
wahren regel iana für georg lucas war es
marx mit der proletarischen revolution
dann kam fukuyama der das nigerianische
moments in der modernen liberalen
demokratie erkannt oder die studie ja
die in der sogenannten singularität
also der verschmelzung unserer gehirne
hegels absoluten geistlos machen
regel ist viel pessimistischer hegel
glaubt die zukunft ist undurchsichtig
durchsichtig mein problem mit markt ist
dass er den kapitalismus
ich meine natürlich den kommunismus
sowie
communism freude ja kommen lisa
kommunismus als zeit der
durchsichtigkeit sie transparenz die
durchsichtigkeit welt in der wir der
geschichte oder unserem system nicht
mehr und fand erklären wir würden mit
unserem kollektiven geist die lage
meistern
ich denke wir lernen aus freud und leid
dass wir nie dahin kommen unser höchstes
ziel sollte nicht die selbst
durchsichtigkeit des sozialen lebens
sein sondern und ich weiß um die ironie
eine gute entfremdung bad eine chronik
über derlei geht eine gute entfremdung
gut alle menschen was könnte das heißen
den veränderungen
das heißt dass wir menschen unsere
entfremdung in dem sinn akzeptieren
müssen dass unsere kommunikation nicht
nur individuen passieren sondern dass
ihn jeder kommunikation das große andere
wirte er gegenwärtig ist wie jacques
lacan es nannte das anonyme system das
uns regulieren große andere aber die
anonymus schichten mit regula diese
normen und erwartungen
ich kann das nicht genug betonen denn
das ist heute meiner meinung nach
betreten
wir sollten die rolle der
ungeschriebenen regeln die unsere
kommunikation regulieren nicht
unterschätzen
es gibt nicht nur explizite regeln zu
jedem system gehört ein weiterer bereich
der vorgibt wie ernst wie die expliziten
regel nehmen sollten
beispiel haben sie ein alltägliches
ritual
ich weiß nicht
nehmen wir an ich wäre reich als sie was
er sicher nicht stimmt und
ich lade sie zum essen ein wir pflegen
das ritual dass sie sich bei der
rechnung etwa sträuben obwohl uns beiden
klar ist dass sie die einladung
schließlich akzeptieren aber den ritual
muss genüge getan werden
ich denke sie stimmen mit mir überein
dass der heutige vulgär populismus der
tramp ismus aber auch die linke mit
ihrer politik correctness solcher
ungeschriebenen gesetze verletzen oder
wegleugnen
politik mein problem in der politik
correctness ist dass sie alles zum
beispiel in der sexualität
ausformulieren will
bei einem besuch einer amerikanischen
universität zeigte man eher die
gedruckten regeln für das sexuelle
verhalten
man darf ihre bluse erst dann auf
knöpfen wenn man vorher ihr
einverständnis eingeholt hat das ist
totale regulierung
ich finde das sehr gefährlich weil wir
nicht so funktionieren
[Musik]
auch ein respektvolles zusammenleben
nicht nur in der sexualität beruht
darauf dass nicht alles gesagt sein muss
und das ist heute bedroht
nothing treffen jetzt haben sie gesagt
das findet man bei bagdad sie haben in
den achtziger jahren in paris studiert
bei seinem schüler und schwiegersohn
cala millor und dieser jacques lacan ist
ganz wichtig für sie und da auch dieser
begriff des realen wir wird jetzt ein
bisschen darüber reden und wir haben
nämlich ein spieler vorbereitet wo man
jacques lacan sieht wir schauen uns das
man kurz bitte
ich sage immer die wahrheit
nicht die ganze denn der ganze wahrheit
zu sagen erreicht man nicht die worte
fehlen
gerade durch dieses unmöglich verbindet
sich die wahrheit mit dem realen
dazu muss ich etwas sagen frage stellen
lacko hat mich stark beeinflusst aber
rhetorisch und punkto verhalten ist ihr
lichts fremder als das was wir gerade
gesehen haben das ist für mich total
fällt
ja das entspricht mir gar nicht die aber
in deutlich sind aber in wart very
important trotzdem ist es wichtig zu
verstehen was lakomy richtigerweise sagt
und hier kommt mein heck realismus
wieder raus er sagt nicht es gibt eine
wahrheit die wir nicht völlig erreichen
können weil uns etwas immer entgleitet
ein punkt ist viel näher bei hegel ja
wir können nicht die ganze wahrheit
sagen sie ist immer antagonistisch und
unbeständig in gothic band gerade im
antagonismus und in der inkonsistenz
liegt aber das es gibt also kein
tieferes reales kann tisches ich kann
dort den kann sich auch
wenn es im programm nehmen wir ein
einfaches beispiel adorno macht in einem
frühen aber guten text über unsere
vorstellung der gesellschaft den selben
punkt wie lacko wenn er darüber spricht
dass es heute zwei vorherrschende
vorstellungen von gesellschaft gibt
einerseits eine individualistische
liberale wonach der einzelne und die
sozialen geflechte aus unserer
interaktion entstehen andererseits eine
von emil durch ein geprägte vorstellung
wonach die gesellschaften erst als
brutalität bestehen woraus sich dann der
einzelne entwickelt
daraus formuliert adorno eine wunderbare
antinori er sagt wir können diesen
antagonismus nicht auflösen es gibt
entweder das eine oder das andere aber
keine synthese und fügt dann hinzu dass
es gerade dieser antagonismus zwischen
dem einzelnen und dem anonymen system
ist was unsere gesellschaft beschreibt
das ist ein typisch italienischer trick
was als hindernis gesehen wird ist
eigentlich die lösung das meint auch
lacke wenn er sagt er sind back to
erreichen das reale über den
antagonismus und die inkonsistenz
aber das ist interessant dass dieses
reale also dieser diese lücke
es ist rein virtuell dahinter gibt es
keine eigentliche realität scheint aber
was ist dieses real wenn mich etwas
verstehen nichts es ist eine rein
formale idee ein fehlender virtueller
referenzpunkt vor dem was wirklich
existiert dahinter gibt es keine
positive
endeffekt
dinge geschehen wenn man verstehen will
was geschieht muss man diese dinge auf
fehlender virtuelle entität die nicht
göttlicher natur ist beziehen auf einen
antagonismus und das zu erreichen was in
tierisch existiert
ja es ist wir haben sozusagen eine
welterklärung sage ich jetzt mal ein
weltbild und irgendetwas das dass das
stört das nicht reinpasst dass wir nicht
erklären können diese unerklärliche rest
der uns ihre irritiert da durch eine
bankenpleite dich ja aber dieser
unaufschiebbare rest und ich beziehe
mich aufstellen ihrer
aufrecht da sind nicht existiert nicht
außerhalb unserer vielen versuche es ist
deren auswirkung das ist ein typischer
gedanke das reale hat keine materialität
wir können es nicht mit unserem geist
erfassen das reale ist das unmöglich
welches durch unser scheitern erst zu
erreichen erst geschaffen wird das ist
edel und lacour wir scheitern aber nicht
in dem sinn dass wir etwas verpassen
sondern wir verpassen etwas aber dieses
etwas ergibt sich erst durch unser
scheitern es zu erreichen
das gehört zur realität dazu
ich sehe das eher kannst in den tag es
gilt nach lage den unterschied zwischen
realität und dem realen zu machen
realität ist das was ist
das reale ist der rein virtuelle
überschuss
[Musik]
ganz ganz banale frage gibt es dieses
reale draußen in der welt zum beispiel
sitzt der kriege pandemie oder sowas das
irgendwie ja auch unser denken
erschüttert kann man das ist es auch
aber so eng gefasst ist es dass die arme
weil wir es nicht dem symbolischen
zuordnen können vielleicht ist er tut so
etwas
gute philosophen wie etwa hans georg
gadamer ja nicht wirklich zu meinem haus
philosophen gehört sagten dass dinge wie
tod und horror nicht in unsere übliche
wahrnehmung der realität integriert
werden können ähnlich wie all diesen
mythologischen beispiele
so stellen wir uns gerne eine glückliche
vergangenheit vor in der das sterben ein
normaler prozess war mann starb in
frieden umgeben von der familie das ist
ein retro aktiver welters das ist es was
lang meint wer der realität blendet
etwas aus in dem sinn dass wir es nicht
in unseren bedeutungs horizont
integrieren können we cannot integrität
innauer horizon oft
genau das ist hier passiert
deshalb mag ich übrigens zürich
nicht allzu weit von hier unterhalb der
universität befindet sich das
statistische cabaret voltaire
es gibt einen schönen mythos wohl rein
anekdotisch und ein fake wie der begriff
da da entstand
lenin liebt in die zu der zeit lebte
leningrad um die ecke gemäss dem mythos
hat levin eine vorführung gesucht und
applaudierend da da gerufen brussig für
jaja und
abgeordneten chat da wie in russian
machines
im bett unfortunately
that between es ist wohl leider nur ein
mythos
moderne kunst und radikale politische
bewegungen schwingen im gleichklang auch
wenn radikale künstler geht die
futuristen in der sowjetunion sich gerne
als künstlerisches gegenstück sahen aber
so funktioniert es nicht
verzeihen sie ich spreche zu viel
wir haben über das reale gesprochen
schwierig zu definieren irgendwie gibt's
das wir können es nicht in unserem
symbol system in unser verständnis
eingehen da gibt es noch die realität
und da spielt er
in stendal konstituieren bollwerk zu
müssen wir jetzt verstehen weil sie
glauben nämlich die realität ist
unvollständig ähnlich wie das die
quantenphysik sagt also zum beispiel ein
elektron hat seinen konkreten bestimmten
ort erst dann wenn wir erst messen und
dazu gibt es ein ganz berühmtes
gedankenexperiment von dem
österreichischen physiker erwin
schrödinger
natürlich wir schauen uns das mal ganz
kurz sagen das ist wirklich schwierig zu
verstehen aufpassen
in einer geschlossenen box befindet sich
ein radioaktives atom ein detektor ein
hammer ein glas mit gift und eine katze
radioaktive atome haben die eigenschaft
zu verfallen man weiß nur nicht genau
wann ein detektor kann den zerfall
messen und ist so programmiert dass er
sobald er den verfall wahrnimmt den
hammer auf das glas mit dem gift fallen
lässt dieses gift tötet sobald es
austritt die katze also sind alle
versuchs elemente vollautomatisiert
miteinander gekoppelt es gibt nun die
zwei möglichkeiten dass das atom
zerfällt und die katze tötet und dass
das atom nicht zerfällt und die katze am
leben bleibt das atom ist aber nun ein
quanten objekt und diese nehmen solange
wir sie nicht beobachten keinen festen
zustand ein demnach befindet sich das
atom auch was den verfall angeht in der
sogenannten super position das heißt
solange wir es nicht beobachten deswegen
befindet sich das alles auch in einer
box ist es verfallen und nicht zerfallen
zugleich was natürlich schwer ist sich
vorzustellen der quantenmechanische
zustände anders sind als das was wir aus
unserem makrokosmos kennen erst wenn wir
in die box gucken dann zwingen wir das
universum sich für eine möglichkeit zu
entscheiden ab dann ist es entweder
zerfallen oder nicht zerfallen und
entsprechend die katze tot oder lebendig
wenn nun aber in der geschlossenen box
das atom zugleich zerfallen und nicht
zerfallen ist muss der detektor auch
zugleich ausgelöst und nicht ausgelöst
seien dadurch hat der hammer das glas
zerstört und nicht zerstört und das gift
es ausgetreten und nicht ausgetreten
demnach müsste solange wir nicht in die
box gucken die katze tot und lebendig
sein wie wir sehen wechselwirken hier
objekte aus dem mikrokosmos mit solchen
aus dem makrokosmos und diese müssten
eigentlich jeweils ihren eigenen
naturgesetzen folgen dass das atom aus
dem mikrokosmos gleichzeitig zerfallen
nicht zerfallen ist ist völlig in
ordnung doch eine katze ist kein quanten
objekte und kann daher keine super
position einnehmen eine katze kann nicht
tot und gleichzeitig lebendig sein und
dieser widerspruch ist das
wahrscheinlich fundamentalste problem
unserer modernen wissenschaft eklatanter
widerspruch der unser denken an eine
fundamentale grenze bringt nämlich dass
wir alle anerkennen müssen dass die
wirklichkeit
widersprüchlich ist in ihrem wesen
drehen bis wir sie beobachten aber
aber sie wissen ja wahrscheinlich dass
einige leute versuchen diese
schlussfolgerung zu umgehen people drei
du dich computer-freak lampe so zum
beispiel die theoretische physikerin
sabine hossenfelder die in deutschland
sehr bekanntesten die an podcasts
physikalische theorie sabine
hossenfelder sie geht zurück zu einstein
behauptet dass diese super position
nichts anderes besagt als das unsere
erkenntnis der realität unverständlich
ist
es gibt keine widersprüche wir wissen
dass einfach nicht wieso das ist
einsteins position gewesen
hier bin ich natürlich für niels bohr
auf kurz und
53 toren berlins war der berühmte
physiker
genau muss man vielleicht dazu sagen
vater von quantum physik und chemie er
ist für mich eines der wirklich größten
genies des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
überhaupt sein
qualifikantin general vielleicht kann
hier wiederholen was ich auch in meinem
buch erwähne nämlich seine bestechende
definition wie ideologie heute
funktioniert
ja ja mit einer antwort auf die frage
warum er ein hufeisen hat erzählen sie
das ja ja ja
die geschichte soll sogar war sein tor
hatte ein haus auf dem land über seine
haustür ging ein hufeisen das böse
geister fernhalten sollte
mein freund besucht die ihnen und sagte
du bist doch als wissenschaftler nicht
abergläubisch warum hast du das ding und
beantwortete natürlich bin ich ein
wissenschaftler ich glaube nicht daran
aber man hat mir gesagt es funktioniert
auch wenn man nicht dran glaubt das ist
geologie
wir sind alle zynisch wir glauben nicht
daran verlassen uns aber irgendwie
darauf dass es funktioniert
aber zurück zu diesem quanten problem es
mag als und spekulativ seien aber in
meinem buch habe ich versucht die
quantenphysik mit schelling zu verbinden
der in seinen weltalter fragmenten
die hypothese formuliert hat dass es
unter unsere realität mit ihren festen
objekten eine andere virtuelle
potenzielle realität gibt die fließend
und vieldeutig ist potenziell idee
beatrice pflichten morgen am tigris
entzogen
ich kehre zurück zum zentralen punkt
auch bohrer hat auf hegel
zurückgegriffen
wo andere vor ihm die grenzen unserer
erkenntnis sein sagte er warum ist nicht
die realität an sich
unbestimmten
die extreme bord
das scheint mir extrem wichtig denn es
erlaubt uns nicht hinter sondern unter
unsere übliche vorstellung der realität
zu klicken die wir immer noch dem
neunzehnten jahrhundert entlehnen welche
in der realität letztlich nichts als
einen leeren raum mit rauf und runter
hüpfenden platzieren
vielleicht darf ich noch ein
faszinierendes beispiel aus einer meiner
bücher erwähnen zu den theologischen
konsequenzen diese unvollständig der
realität
in einer einführung in die philosophie
von nicolas fern der sehr analytisch
vorgeht und meine theorie wahrscheinlich
hast habe ich eine wunderbare bemerkung
gefunden er sagt die realität ist
unvollständig weil gott faul ist
nicht vollständig gebracht
ja er vergleicht die schöpfung gottes
mit einem videogame indem man schießen
uns die straße entlang geht und im
hintergrund einen wald
der programmierer hat ihn aber nicht in
allen details dargestellt
weil man sich im spiel ähnlich dorthin
bewegt hatte die details ausgespart
fragt nun was wäre wenn er sich mit gott
auch so verhielte und er die menschen
führt zu beschränkt befand als das jesu
katholische ebene erreichen könnten und
er sich die arbeit sparte diese fertig
zu programmieren
videospiel dahin geht dann zieht das
unscharfe haus aber nicht weil wir als
mannschaft sind es ist einfach und was
wenn unsere realität so wäre dann sehr
kluges gott gedacht hat ja das ist der
gedanke dahinter das ist auch die
haltung kirkegaard wenn man ihn richtig
versteht aber wir können später darüber
sprechen musik
vielleicht ja interessiert mich
dazu müsste ich erst aufgepasst kalte
wetter zu sprechen kommen
wenn man pascal genau liest sagt er
nicht wenn du nicht an gott glaubt ruhe
so als ob und der glaube folgen nein
wenn man genau hinsieht sagt er wenn du
glaubst dass gott existiert aber nicht
entsprechend handeln verhältst du dich
wie jeder andere gläubiger dass es nicht
besonders interessant
wenn du nicht an gott glaubt und dich
verhältst als ob es ihn nicht gibt bist
du ein säkularer philosoph
interessant wird es aber wenn man die
beiden positionen in einem paradox
verknüpft also in der humanistisch
agnostischen haltung wonach ich weiß
dass es keinen gott gibt aber ich mich
um der tradition willen so verhalten als
ob er existierte
ganz verrückt wird es aber mit
kirkegaard der eigentlich sagt ich weiß
dass gott gibt aber ich verhalte mich so
als ob er nicht existierte das sollte
auch unsere haltung sein wenn man gott
durch unseren heutigen gott ersetzt
nämlich den wissenschaftlichen
determinismus
gemäß der wissenschaft sind wir nicht
frei aber ich nehme mir heraus etwas
verrücktes zu tun so zu handeln als ob
ich frei wäre
archiv
wir müssen noch zum kapitalismus kommen
irgendwann
mich interessiert all diese
theoretischen überlegungen wie hängen
die jetzt zusammen mit ihrer
gesellschaftspolitischen forderungen das
ihren kapitalismus überwinden müssen
also erste frage gibt's was ist der
konnex
[Musik]
bin und bleibe max ist allerdings aus
kritischer distanz ohne die
marxistischen folgerungen zum
kapitalismus zu teilen
gut wie kommen wir zuerst zu den guten
seiten des kapitalismus
es liegt ja heute im trend sich der
dritten welt mit ihren überbleibsel
alter traditionen zuzuwenden und auf
deren grundlage den globalen widerstand
gegen den kapitalismus zu schüren
mit all den schrecklichen neben
produkten schafft die globalisierung
aber auch raum für neues denken
es war immer teil des marxistischen
dogmas dass eine neue ordnung aus dem
kapitalismus hervorgeht
dies gelingt aber nur durch den
kapitalismus weil er all die
traditionellen werte und ihr gehirn
zerstört
und marx hat sich dazu eindeutig
geäußert
ich habe hier ganz klar nicht die
position dass uns lokale traditionen aus
afrika oder lateinamerika helfen können
der einzige freiraum ist der
kapitalismus
kapitalismus das problem bei marx ist
seine vorstellung der überwindung des
kapitalismus
max idee des kommunismus war
kapitalismus ohne kapitalismus
er wollte die kapitalistischen aspekte
wie produktivität und ständige
entwicklung beibehalten
wissen sie wo marx vorstellung im
gesetzt wurde
china ist für mich das größte paradox
und die größte gefahr heute
kurz gefasst kann ich das so begründen
helfen
wir die alte linke des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts hatten zwei dinge am
kapitalismus
und einerseits dem brutalen markt
wettbewerb
der wenige reiche und millionen von
armen produziert hält andererseits die
starke staatliche kontrolle hat kinder
nicht genau das auf sehr effiziente art
umgesetzt
[Musik]
ich bewundere china zwar für seine
vorgehensweise dumm sind sie nicht sie
sehen die probleme mit dem liberalen
kapitalismus aber langfristig sie in
ihrer auslegung keine lösung
haben sie eine utopie ist das oder
sieglose frage was stellen sie sich vor
was was meint ihr ich bin ganz heliane
ich fürchte mich vor utopie wenn es eine
sein muss kann die einer guten truppe
ist eine gute entfremdung
das ist jetzt sehr persönlich aber wir
wissen heute dass die traditionelle
sozialdemokratie und der realsozialismus
abgedankt haben
einzelne verzweifelte linke klammern
sich an eine lokale basisdemokratie da
lebt man im kleinen authentischen
kommunen wo man sich regelmäßig trifft
um festzulegen wie man die kinder
geschult was man mit der umwelt macht
kann er keine schlimmere welt vorstellen
jeden nachmittag darüber zu sprechen
woher man das wasser und den strom
bezieht
ich will dass sich ein anonymer nicht
allzu repressiver mechanismus um solche
dinge kümmert
aber das muss irgendwo da draußen
geschehen undurchsichtig für mich darin
liegt der einzige freiraum
bei einer veranstaltung in spanien hat
man nicht auch zu meiner op befreien
meine antwort hat sie schockiert und
angriff mich an ich sagte rationaler
bürokratischer kapitalismus das ist
sozialismus man muss den markt zu lassen
heute angesichts all der probleme den
krieg der pandemie den drohenden hunger
der emigration
geht es nicht darum den markt
abzuschaffen
eine weltregierung würde unfassbare
korruption bedeuten das kann man ganz
vergessen wir müssen wege zur
internationalen kooperation und zur
minimalen kontrolle tapson
international cooperation and minimale
direct control markets local global
warming man schaue sich doch bloß die
globale erwärmung an
letzten sommer herrschten an meinen
lieblings orten in der welt in vancouver
seattle und portland temperaturen von 50
grad
wissen sie als die ursache ist es ist
nicht die lokale verschmutzung die
gesamte luftzirkulation am nordpol
ahrkreis ist unterbrochen
die lösung findet sich einzig in einer
engen in starken internationalen
zusammenarbeit was aber schwierig ist
weil wir stets wenn wir in
schwierigkeiten stecken zuflucht im
protektionismus suchen
es geht um unser überleben
vergessen wir also das zentralkomitee
der sed oder
andere lösungswege des 20 jahrhunderts
aber es braucht nicht wie die jugend
fordert einen systemwechsel
was
wissen sie wie ich mich heute definiere
zum schrecken aller meiner linken
freunde
mit kommunismus meine ich dass wir unser
globales system in bezug auf das soziale
unternehmertum und eine globale
gesundheitsfürsorge ernsthaft verändern
müssen
an intelligenten oder raten
konservativen mag ich eine qualität die
schon lenin an ihn schätzte wie er
schrieb sie meinen es ernst
es sind keine billigen liberalen die
eine wohlfahrt nach wunsch versprechen
ein guter konservativer überlegt zuerst
welche gefahren und wie hoch der preis
dafür sein wird ich spreche also nicht
über eine police muss aller trump
populisten whatever hat diese
konservatismus es im alltag zu tun wie
dem mit dem zunehmenden alters in sie
konservativer geworden in ihren
ansichten
because i'm nein ich bin ja immer noch
radikal weil ich denke es braucht
radikale veränderungen
wir laufen mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit
in eine krise hinein die globale
erfahrung wie sie jetzt in indien
sichtbar wird bedroht die
nahrungsmittelproduktion was zu weiterer
migration führt
ich habe mir kürzlich bei einer reise
nach dubai ein bild davon gemacht als
die temperaturen auf 55 grad stiegen
selbst die leute von dort sagten mir
dass man sich daran nicht gewöhnen kann
da ist ein leben unmöglich es braucht
also große veränderungen das problem ist
dass ohne krieg zu schaffen
dasselbe gilt auch für die armut
gerade deshalb missfällt mir wiederum
zum in sechs in meiner linken freunde
deren sicht auf die immigration wonach
wir unsere türen öffnen sollten wenn wir
das tun kommen millionen und den
populisten laufen die menschen in
scharen zu das würde zu einem
bürgerkrieg führen
die lösung liegt nicht mehr öffnen der
türen sondern vereinfacht gesagt zu
überlegen warum sie hierher kommen dazu
müssen wir das ganze system ändern
dazu darf man ein problem bei der
migration nicht ausblenden hierher
schaffen es ja meist nicht die ärmsten
viele haben einen kriminellen
hintergrund
es braucht geld um die schmuggler zu
bezahlen deshalb bin ich für einen
anderen ansatz
dass ich heute viel für die welt
schreiben eine moderat konservative
zeitung ist an sich ein paradox ich habe
ihm gesagt dass ich immer noch eine art
kommunistin wenn ein moderat konservativ
als ich mich erstaunt zeigte über die
plattform die sie mir boten sagten sie
kein problem wir sind auch moderat
kommunistisch konservativ wie hieß noch
in casablanca das war der beginn einer
wunderbaren freundschaft
sie haben gesagt ziel ist gute
entfremdung ich habe ihnen hier einen
spieler mitgebracht ja
wenn sie da rein schauen was sehen sie
da ist das gute entfremdung es ist etwas
absolut schrecklich
mir ob ich hasse spiegel ich hasse es
mich selbst auf den bildschirm zu sehen
ich habe mir keinen einzigen meiner
filme angeschaut
sie haben so viele filme gemacht und nie
angeschaut das
ist keine postmoderne arroganz ich meine
es wird mit all meinem nervösen ticks
und all dem ich halte es nicht aus nicht
länger als eine minute auf dem
bildschirm zu sehen ich kann es nicht
das ist eine andere person oder was sie
nein
nein ich bin es und das ist das problem
ich mag nicht was ich da sehe einen
abstoßenden typ mit nervösen tick ich
bin ein schriftsteller obwohl ich oft
und gerne spricht
für das was sie hier zeigen
ja aber für mich ist das ein problem
okay was sie identifizieren sich mit den
texten ganz genau und deshalb
dieses gespräch sollte man nicht sparen
sondern leichte bücher lesen hören sie
sagen die andere leute
dass kunden aber ich will will ich mache
etwas anderes ich schaue es mir an aber
ohne bild einzig die stimme
[Musik]
ich schlage ihnen eine nette
manipulation vor warum bringen sie
dieses gespräch anstatt mit untertiteln
mit meiner stimme im hintergrund und
einem sprecher der die übersetzung liest
sie können den inhalt dann manipulieren
und mich falsch übersetzen ich bin von
natur aus böse
ja wir sind schon leider fast am ende
des gesprächs schluss wären eine gute
frage
sie können nicht nach dem sinn vom leben
und vom tod fragen und ich liefere ihnen
dann irgendeinen 10 buddhistischen
quatsch wie klatschen sie mit einer hand
ich wollte sie jetzt fragen ich schenke
ihnen hier etwas von diesen dingern sie
können auswählen das ist sich die die
schlussfrage
diesen hier
weisheit ist bei definition dummheit
dazu habe ich eine ganze theorie ich
habe mich zur kamera sieht sie können
sitzt perfekt
wie so viele definiere ich mich selbst
paradoxerweise als atheistischer christ
aber was jesus christus sagt ist
verrückt er ist alles andere als weise
er bringt einen radikalen umsturz für
mich sind sprichwörter der inbegriff von
weisheit
ich weiß nicht wie das bei ihnen ist
aber in meiner sprache kann ich mir
nichts ekelhaftes vorstellen als
konformistischen sprichwörter denn egal
was man tut es findet sich immer ein
weiser spruch zur rechtfertigung
sie ihre ski an etwas und haben erfolg
als weiser typ sage ich ihn dann nur wer
riskiert gewinnt
damit rechtfertige ich das eingegangene
risiko
sie tun etwas und scheitern
ich nehme ein slowenisches sprichwort
und sage ihnen
urinieren nicht gegen den wind
das ist die wahrheit die in der weisheit
steckt sie kann retro aktiv schlicht
alles rechtfertigen ich brauche keine
weisen sprüche die uns eine falsche
sicherheit vermitteln
worin sie stünde dann weisheit
ich bin dem einmal auf parodistische art
und weise nachgegangen israel vor einem
publikum wo einzelne zuhörer mit
eintätowierten nummern mir sogar
beipflichten
ich sprach darüber dass es angesichts
ihrer völlig verzweifelten situation es
wohl das widerlichste gewesen wäre wenn
irgendein weiser typ ein nazi etwa den
hungernden juden gesagt hätte
leiden ist teil des lebens es findet
sich überall ein quäntchen glück selbst
hier das wäre obszön und dass sie ist
für mich weisheit wir brauchen aber
verrücktheit wir brauchen gut
durchdachte aber verrückte entscheiden
das nehme ich das schlusswort danke für
diese tolle stunde und ich habe viel
glück ich bin sehr dankbar
zu dir und die würde sagen dass weil du
nicht ein schlechter mann war wenn wir
das volk was folgt
ich verkörpere das volk wenn wir die
macht übernommen haben gehen sie nicht
in den gulag aber zwei bis dreijährigen
zwangsarbeit werden angebracht
ja danke ihnen fürs mitdenken falls sie
jetzt lust bekommen haben was ich
vermute islam scheck nicht nur zusehen
und zuhören sondern ihnen auch zu lesen
wir verlosen diese bücher hier signiert
versteht sich vom arthur schreiben sie
einfach ein kommentar bei mir
instagram oder auf unserer website unter
der rubrik mehr zur sendung nächste
woche spricht barbara bosch mit dem
aktivisten raul krauthausen und dem
philosophen stefan rieder über die frage
wie wir uns für das gute in der welt
stark machen können und wie viel
engagement es brav und jetzt gleich
zeigt die sternstunde kunst wie
krankheit und tod seit jeher ein motor
des kunstschaffens waren bis heute
bleiben dran und bis bald
[Musik]